welcome to this video playing jakub
church jakub church from from sweden and
playing the so called double fianchetto
ganked the king's indian a king's indian
structure this is an opening that I'm
have played a lot in in the tournament
chess even a dumb it's quite quite
interesting and a fairly good antidote
against the Kings Indian a successor was
somewhat surprising news it's not not
really if it fit well with them the
fianchetto I think okay so what is this
probably just taking them Knight takes
Knight xe6 should be excellent for me
and more justice I didn't even consider
hmm yeah yet both looks good for white
Bishop Bishop takes us not bad at all I
what's so Queen takes oh ok let's let's
do this yeah so let's see if do I have
something better than the simple captcha
ok so that's certainly nice for white
but what's now my pawn would still be on
b3 then I could even just just take this
and get into an excellent isolated pawn
position with the pollen b3 that is not
so attractive as the knight on c3 year
won't be covered this is some weak
square so probably probably I shouldn't
take but I have this attractive move
getting the Queen into the center
quickly and after me if you place Queen
f6 which looks I thought looks normal ok
he didn't do that hmm interesting
okay yeah of course I don't want to
trade Quincy I'm giving him the D file
it's not advisable the question is where
to put the Queen this is son not not so
easy to answer yeah maybe even here
keeping this pin active and really
mechanically preventing e5 if I would
jam queen bee to was probably not bad
okay but it prevents Queen a five and
what not my idea simply Knight c3 and
roti one and look at this fantastic
bishop on g2 this is every every closed
type of position players dream every d4c
for player what one said to have this
kind of vision ok he's going Knight g4
and if I tech the night somehow he's
probably going to play five so where to
put the Queen hmm to be five maybe not
clear move like we near four runs into e
5 which not I don't really want to allow
that with the temple
yeah I guess queen bee five I don't I
don't know don't have so many squares
available so really that is surprising
yeah it should be good really the
surface position type the question is
how to exactly play this now be six this
week but how to play Bishop d7 I can
take b7 he cannot really move cannot
really move maybe this one intending
look if tending night a form yeah this
is certainly a good move not sure if it
is the best one but it's a good move
tonight a for sm this is threat now SS
maybe nighty for 2d six okay night a for
now
well that's alright so good move I can
even play rock d 1 let's say rook a
sixer play what do you want the special
bond c 8 is almost wrapped so very
tricky for him to to get it into play I
don't really know how he covers b6 yeah
on a move like rook g6 I play rock t 1
and then then it's basically over yeah
but Knight b6 lets the bishop here don't
think he considered this thoroughly just
a double attack hey Dan c8 yeah I can
take him check
rookie to this Bishop f3 so not even
that one is serve is on black resigns ok
that's a let's review this e six is a
slightly strange move and it does not
really help to weaken the dark squares I
mean maybe it's not fatal but this is
already bit fishy don't think that he
can equalize after that if you consider
this like ed this is comparable to a
Tosh with the bishop on g7 and I'm not
sure that it says this is some well
placed him even taking and Bishop d4 and
the 93 looks looks like a good idea but
that's better than the game without
without much doubt this is a fantastic
position why I have so much pressure on
the isolated pawn very very good so he
went here and here Jericho think windy
for us just a good move taking us some
is too too early even a position like
that the problem has mentioned is that
my night is not stable here he can get
counter play with rook c8 here and okay
i can now can maybe i can get it oops
not that i can maybe get it in time to
deform but yeah this is of course nice
for white but
i already i'm playing for more than just
this end gammage queen f6r thought would
be the only move but it's it's very
uncomfortable it's very uncomfortable
all based on this fantastic bishop yeah
okay Quincy five is also moved here I
think Quinn b6 is just losing maybe if
maybe this is already beyond repair and
it's possible that he cannot even ever
move his bishop I'm ready for rock d1
and rub see one the computer is already
on on almost plus two so it's very very
hard yeah and ta probably must play
Bishop d7 give up the porn this is this
is beyond repair really okay this was a
blunder but what should like to if he
covers like that I play rook t1 and he
cannot exchange so this is just now here
not to d7 not to d7 am getting this end
and he has no way to prevent it so after
rook to e1 yes to play a rotten mood I
grew gave aid and then it's it's a
question out to continue he never can
move this bishop maybe it's good even to
to to drop this night back and continue
like this it's already it's it's that
you cannot save that he really must
recapture with the pawn here with the
poems with the pond and this is
certainly a playable position it's not
great but it's it's playable yeah very
quick 15 minute game but still
interesting thanks for watching